si vous rêvez d'aller sur Mars on peut y
aller dans un hôtel qui est absolument
dingue c'est un hôtel dans l'univers
bien évidemment de l'espace plutôt mars
mais également un peu Star Wars tout
dans cet hôtel est dans cet univers que
ce soit les couloirs que ce soit
l'ascenseur on le voit également au
travers du bar et si vous regardez par
la fenêtre et bien vous avez une lumière
orangée les vitres sont complètement
teintées en fait pour vous plonger dans
l'univers de Star Wars dans l'univers de
la planète Mars et lorsque vous arrivez
dans les chambres c'est là où ça devient
dingue parce que vous avez une vraie
cabine avec toute cette déco inspirée
avec des bandes oranges une chambre avec
un grand lit de place avec une télé
totalement intégrée que vous avez
également un petit tableau de commande
qui est intégré et vous allez pouvoir me
dire piloter la climatisation
l'éclairage est pas mal de petites
choses et le détail la même jusque dans
la salle de bain vous allez avoir un
distributeur de savon totalement
personnalisé un pare-douche totalement
bleu aux couleurs de la station spatiale
et même le papier ne pas déranger où on
dit que l'équipage doit venir se reposer
cet hôtel vous le trouvez au Futuroscope
c'est l'hôtel station cosmos donc si
vous avez envie de faire vos valises et
d'avoir la sensation de partir voyager
sur Mars ben vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à faire